boondocks is so good jacket since you
said that there's so much good animation
it's really stunning
yeah are you working on your own project
now what uh
can you talk about it yeah but try is
there a deadline
no i hope never i don't want to ever be
i don't want anyone to quote tweak my
accomplishments
that's my biggest fear we're always
attached i'm gonna say
that's my biggest fear it's like
something to be announced and then above
it is like
in 2016 he called me fat and it's like
uh well just don't announce it just put
the show out don't even say i'm not even
anywhere near yeah
well i wonder how much the animation has
has
influenced you as a performer what i've
noticed is i if you guys this
is like a very real plug and not like a
show busy thing you got you and and um
jack fox have a doomsday mixtape which
is a podcast but it just
it divulges into some of the best riffs
that are
it could be sketches it could be a key
and peeled type show
in that i'm howling laughing i'm like
falling asleep
let's do a podcast and it's upsetting
so i wonder how much animation has
changed that in your mind when you start
thinking of things as not because i
think before you're doing like concept
jokes where you're like here's this idea
i know it's unpopular let me argue for
the lawyer thing and i think now at
least what you guys are doing on that
podcast
seems like you're you're essentially
talking out sketches especially with you
and alex
uh you guys have like these 13-minute
ideas that you just perfectly break down
and it's funny every beat of the way
and that just wasn't the way that i was
raised to be funny
you know i mean like it was just like i
was i was raised in such
short bursts who's the loudest who can
say the
most abrasive sentence at the back of
this bus
who can get the most amount of attention
in this lunchroom as fast as possible
and so you can't really break down a
whole story about how you broke your leg
on a ferris wheel in
middle school and that's why you
couldn't go on a date with something
like i did that was
and that's my greatest adversity story i
was just like that i feel like
that feels like it's aimed at roasting
either one of us
and i'm like touched good sir great
great example but it's like i would
watch it like these guys are
brilliant first of all it was my arm and
a tilt-a-whirl
[Laughter]
it was just and moses is right moses has
known me since i started comedy and like
he's
there like it's just been more evil like
i've evolved from
the same way i've been telling jokes
since me and him were like in our early
twenties
jack and i started open mics he would
essentially say the most outrageous
thing
and then build the case around why that
was true until people were on his side
but yeah a level of confidence you know
why we're at these terrible open mics
was just
something i learned from and it was like
oh i didn't know you could do that
on the other side with maria i used to
intern at ucb and i would just
watch your stuff over and over again i
didn't know
you could leave the audience in that i
feel like you go so deep into character
that a lot of the time you're like
checking with the audience can i
continue here's this joke do you like it
it feels like you're
so laser focused on these characters
that you just leave and you do the
character it was that
always something that you had or did you
learn that from somewhere because i
that is something that i've directly
stolen from you oh god
no i had i think i just i'm not i'm an
introvert
so i'm not i'm not super comfortable
it's not my go-to to be
with people uh usually so
you're not like look at this guy's shirt
look at you flannel again
which i love as an audience member like
i love oh my god you saw my sweater and
my necklace
yeah like i love that but i
i am so awkward and sort of a cold fish
type person like i've tried to be
um more gregarious on stage and it's
just everyone's like
oh you know so
here's a story of you know maple leaves
just didn't feel right well and i think
it's the way i grew up
my dad would give me three minutes to
talk at the dinner table
or i think it was five minutes he would
set a timer um
that's crazy that's so crazy because
i was quiet and my sister my mom just
talked to like they're they're big
interrupters and they can just talk and
talk and talk
talking forever and um i just
i will be silent and i've i've actually
done that before i was once on a show in
australia whereas on the show
was a chat show for a full hour it was
supposed to be where you're supposed to
jump in and
like is it the great debate
uh uh yes i said nothing for 60 minutes
i've seen that change you're not lying
you're not lying wait
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry can we go
back
to the to the thing you just said so is
it so i guess
is it this is your chance to talk as if
you didn't get to speak and this is your
chance to get it or is it
you need to talk bro we need you to
actually converse with his family
um no it was this is your chance like
this is your chance
everyone's got to be quiet um because
otherwise i won't
i won't get to get to talk because i
would try to say something
but i would just feel kind of like and i
still feel the same way with my family
like my sister's
hilarious and she's just louder than me
and so um yeah that's part of the
longing to be
amplified and lit in front of thousands
is uh due to her
so the timer goes off and it's a hard
like before your punch line of your
story
it's just no more it's a hard out which
is what i'm calling my disappearance at
the age of 75.
do you ever feel guilty that you're
selling something out like i feel guilty
sometimes about like exploiting a
poverty narrative
and growing up homeless sometimes do you
ever feel like you're leaning too much
in that for industry sakes of like
generals like we were talking about
reviews like i know you went to a
white nationalist meeting yeah how much
of that was for the show and how much
was that
for your genuine curiosity as a human
being it's for everything i do is for my
the genuine curiosity of of my life
or like my investing in my sincere side
means going to like white nationalist
meetings and i've gone to
churches and mosques and places that
jews shouldn't or
places that jews usually aren't and i've
gone to
different countries when i was in south
korea for the olympics my brother
my brother was in south korea competing
in the olympics which is a whole other
thing
wait he doesn't want you to talk about
him hey i just wanted to keep a low
profile
he doesn't want to be mocked but i i
don't feel guilty talking about what it
means to be jewish i would feel guilty
if i talked about
jews but it's certainly not for like
industry's sake because like you say
it's not super unique
to be a jew but like that is a big part
of my identity so when i talk about that
and i have things that sometimes people
go oh man your shows are so like
personal but like
i have different things that i think are
personal like i don't talk about my
romantic relationships or my
interpersonal relationships on stage
because that to me is like
my private life i always feel guilty now
you know that i do stuff about my
family and it's like well yeah i'm
trying to just talk about myself
now because i yeah realize how
that can be hurtful to people um
but i started talking about i'm in a
jillion 12 step groups or
three three three and um
you know one of the things that i i
sincerely respect about those things
are that they they are safe spaces
you know too but then they are so
funny that i feel like i
have to tell jokes about them because
it it like i i have to i have to say
one of the rules of 12-step cults is
that you're not supposed to say that
you're in a specific group
um like you're not supposed to say i'm
um you just say cults maria
yes that's a fair description though
that's why i've been turned off by
anything
that's like that of like i mean
they're cults because they have these
weird rules where you go i mean
the one thing that i like that makes it
less occult in 12 step
is that it's free number two free number
three
they can't kick you out like even if i
go to all the meetings and you know
bring a bottle of jack daniels and i'm
eating an ice cream cake
with a stolen porn dvd all anyone will
say is you newcomer keep coming back
but you're scooping the ice cream cake
with the porn dvd
with the prawn dvd oh my god it's not
being used
you come back the next week with
slightly lower proof alcohol and they're
like okay so you're working
you're just you're getting there no no
it's great to have you here have you
ever tried to push it though
like what what what could i do um oh
yeah i mean i do talk i've started
talking about in my zoom shows like
about which ones i'm in uh which feels
like it feels like i shouldn't um
because it is this one private thing
in my life that i've felt um
yeah like somehow i shouldn't break the
rule
or it's disrespectful or something yeah
and sincerity and all that stuff so
anyways it's um it's odd to be able to
have something that is private and
important to you but
also how can you share the
ridiculousness of it
as as well so that's what i'm having
trouble with right now
is family members even though it's my
experience that this happened
have asked me to not do certain things
or they've tried to correct the record
even though
this is my experience or i'm bending it
because it's funny
how do you handle that responsibility as
far as like i'm about to put out
especially never
we'll see when that happens but i i
genuinely wonder cause it's like stuff
that means something to me
i feel better that i can process this
pain and make people laugh
uh but the people that i'm talking about
are like you know i see it different
actually happened this way i mean i've
told
my sister's written three books i said
awesome you
you tell your side about childhood or
about our religion
about childhood about memoirs about um
stuff and and and i didn't you know
edit her experience about um
[Music]
yeah like she had a whole one hilarious
point of view where she
she said the reason she beat me up so
much as a kid
was because she was she knew i was too
sensitive and she was trying to make me
tougher
so i'd be ready for the real world and
i'm like
really yeah i guess it seems like
the hard part is she beat you up to a
timer
exactly i think you were just 12
and you were uh having a terrible time
and you just thought
i think i'll punch this kid in the gut
at least she offered a reason
none of my bullies ever submitted in
writing why they were bullying me
exactly so as a performer how much
responsibility do you have
to be like well no i know it's
entertaining for the crowd and it's
it's my experience which is this versus
protecting someone that didn't sign up
to be in the entertainment industry or
to have their
dirty laundry aired out the first time i
was ever on tv i talked about how
fire my mom's must have been
so i i've only spoken pretty positively
about
the people like the first joke i've ever
made it's a two-part story
yeah that one too it was just like my
mom's is so fast the only reason
why i'm dope and
you can tell who's people who you can
tell who has terrible mom by their
behavior
like if you meet someone and tag tag
punch punch if they act like this you
know their mama is dry
and then you know i was 21 at the time
and then kami switzer was like yeah we
can just put that
on tv yeah and my mother is a principal
of a high school at the time
and they all saw the joke and she is now
a legend
that's hilarious nice you're principal
night just a bunch of 15
16 year old boys trying to mess with
some that's above they pay great
[Music]
my mom had a great attitude towards that
you know
stuff too like she um i think
she she did just pass away and my dad
was
decluttering a few after that hours
after she died
wow and um that's a bad way to process
things as far as like yeah i could use
it
we got to clean up we just need to like
put things somewhere well we're not
gonna need any of this anymore
let's make a trip to goodwill um he uh
got a he he handed my sister and i uh a
shoebox
and he said very solemnly um
in it were a large uh
high quality uh purple plastic dildo
vibrator
and then a a small butterfly style
vibrator and he said she would have
wanted you
girls to have these oh my goodness
and it's true it's true she would i i
said yeah
i'll take them but my sister said no you
will not and she saged them
and then threw them in the trash she
saved them to pass on to her children
these were yours that would have been so
sweet it's like a family watch
did you want to hang on to it for the
sentimental value or just like
for me and my head about growing poor
and like the money like those are those
things those are
pricey that's what i thought i thought
that's like 200 bucks down the rainbow
shipping
vintage vibrators they well they were
brand new i mean these were some
good-looking models i like that it's
passed down like a sword yeah i really
hope there's like someone that works at
bloomhouse listening because i think
that
i got haunted by my mom's vibrator the
come on bro this is like right there
easy money oh my god it's so true
it's the ghost of everyone she thought
of while she was using it
her boyfriend from high school roger
gets he was jewish
and it was probably the reason my mom
was a an honorary member of hadassah
for somebody else i'll check at the
meeting on tuesday maria i'll see if
anyone knows that's so
funny